What drives price movement in the
market? On the chart, we see candles,
lines, indicators,
but these are all consequences.
What if we could see the cause?
Price moves when somebody buys or sells.
But most orders aren't even visible on
the chart. They sit and wait above price
or below price. They create support and
resistance levels. Heat map makes these
invisible orders visible. [music]
You see where they concentrate, how
market participants interest changes and
all of this in a real time. Now we will
break down how this works from the
inside. how to read colors, slices,
levels, and how to use this in making
trading decisions. We will be using ATA
atas platform for this. It's a
professional trading platform with
advanced volume analysis tools. Heat map
is one of them. Everything I show you
today, clusters, footprint, volume
profile, it's all collected in atas and
[music] ready to use. Let's go.
We need to start with the explanation.
What is bit and what is ask? When I zoom
in, I start seeing footprints. It's
something like a microscope for the
candle. There are bits on the left side
and there are asks on the right side.
Left side represents aggressive sells or
passive buys
and right side represent aggressive buys
and passive sells. Let me break this
down simply. Aggressive buy you want to
enter now. You click market order and
take whatever price is available. You
eat through the sell orders that are
waiting as if buy. You are patient. You
place a limit order below current price
and wait. You become liquidity that
someone else will hit. Same logic for
sells just reversed. So when you see the
footprint, left side shows aggressive
sellers hitting waiting by orders. right
side shows aggressive buyers hitting
waiting sell orders.
This is crucial to understand because
when we look at current price levels, we
can see where these orders are stacking
up. We are currently at this price. Now
imagine [clears throat] the situation.
There are obviously some waiting orders.
Somebody wants to sell at this price
above the current [music] price.
Let's say 10 contracts. Then somebody
wants to sell at this level for example
five contracts. Then someone else will
sell at this level 15 contracts and
somebody wants to sell at this level 10
contracts. All these market participants
wait for the price to come to these
levels. The price can for example go
downwards at first then changes the
direction and starts going upwards and
as soon as it hits this level those 10
contracts will be sold only when the
price hits the level. If the market
continued [music]
downwards then these 10 contracts, these
five contracts, these 15 contracts won't
be sold at all obviously because price
will not hit those levels. This is very
important to understand.
So this is the market theory. This is
how the market works. There are waiting
limit orders in the market and there
obviously has to be aggressive buyers or
sellers who buy or sell and move the
market that way because without
aggressive buyers or sellers there
obviously won't be any price movement.
Let's say the market is in an uptrend
and I want to join this uptrend and I
want to buy let's say 20 contracts of
S&P 500 and I want to be in the position
now without waiting without waiting for
any pullback. I don't want to risk being
not filled and state in the market. I
want to join the trend. I want to
purchase 20 contracts of S&P 500. So I
will click at market buy. I'm not going
to buy limit through waiting order and
hope for the pullback for the pullback
to the [music] downside to the
downtrend. I want to join the trend
immediately. I purchase 20 contracts. In
this situation, there must be so-called
liquidity. There must be the opposite
side at the market, somebody who is
willing to sell. So these 20 contracts I
get 10 contracts at 685425.
Then I have 10 contracts of S&P 500 but
I wanted 20. So I need to go one tick
higher and purchase these five
contracts. Now I have 15 contracts but I
wanted 20. So I need to purchase five
contracts at the price of price of
685475.
And then I have total of 20 contracts
where I purchased 10 contracts [music]
at the f at the price of 685425,
five contracts at [music] 685 5450
and five contracts at 685420.
So my average price is somewhere here. I
guess this is the average price. [music]
But I'm in the position now. What
happened? I bought the wall actually.
[music] I bought the barrier which was
here. Those two contracts [music] and
the market
moved one tick upwards.
Then I move then I bought this wall
these waiting orders a barrier to move
upwards and then the market moved one
tick upwards and then I was able to buy
these five contracts. So my buying price
was worse
if I waited here like this guy. I
[music] would have purchased at 685375
at the exact price.
But because the market moved upwards
meanwhile I'm in the position unlike
this guy or these guys these market
participants they are still waiting for
the pullback. But if the market develops
really fast and without hesitation
upwards
then those guys are not in the position
and I am with a slightly worse price but
I am in the position. So this is in a
nutshell what bits and asks represent.
Now this window is called smart dome in
atas and it shows us the waiting orders.
You remember when I spoke about 20
waiting orders, 10 waiting orders,
[music] 15 waiting orders and so on and
so on. This is the current price. We
moved slightly upwards.
It's here. And you see that at 685
there are 27 waiting orders.
So if I want to join the [music] trend
and purchase for example 30 contracts
[music] then I get 27 contracts at this
level. Then the market move moves one
tick above and I get three contracts
from these 29 waiting orders. And then
there will be 26 orders remaining and we
will be at this level. not at this level
anymore, but at this level because I
move the market two ticks to the
upwards.
And on the other side, if somebody wants
to purchase at a better price, better
than the current price, then there are
26 people waiting at this level to
purchase S&P 500 at 6852.
and they hope for the reversal to be
able to purchase and they hope that the
market reverses again and they will join
the uptrend. They have a fixed price.
They have a [music] price which won't
change 6852
but as mentioned before that there's the
risk that they won't get filled because
the market can do anything. the market
can go upwards from this time and they
will be waiting actually without being
filled.
So this is the difference between the
left side and the right side. When you
hear somebody talking about the left
side then he means bits
and bits mean waiting limit orders.
Waiting by limit orders.
Smart dome is the future. Smart dome
shows us only the waiting orders on the
left side, on the bit side, and on the
right side, ask side. These guys on the
right side want to sell and these guys
want to buy. With footprint, there's a
slightly different situation because
footprint shows us past.
Smart dome shows us the future and
footprint shows [music] us the past.
This footprint shows us what happened
and 10:00 15 minutes. And these numbers
represent the amount of the S&P 500
contracts on the left side. Which means
somebody purchased here. 25 contracts
were purchased here. But 25 contracts
was also sold here because somebody
wanted to purchase and waited. [music]
So somebody must have actually sold to
them. Okay, let me pause here and
quickly recap the key difference. Think
of it this way. Footprint shows you what
already happened. Someone bought,
someone sold. Done. Those numbers are
frozen in time. You open this chart next
week. Same numbers. Smartdome shows you
what's waiting to happen. These are live
orders sitting in the market right
[music] now. Someone wants to buy here.
Someone wants to sell here. But here is
the thing. These numbers change
constantly. People add orders, cancel
orders, move them around. That's why
Smart Doom is dynamic.
And heat mapap.
Heat map takes these changing smart dome
numbers and shows you how they developed
over time where interest is building
where it's fading all through color. Now
you get why this is powerful. Let's keep
going. Now we are back in the candle
chart with [music] uh smart dome still
visible and I will show you one thing.
I switched to 10-second chart which
means each candle represent 10 seconds.
It t it took 10 seconds to open the
candle [music] at this level and close
it at this level. The next candle opened
here and [music] in 10 seconds closed
here. So we have actually kind of slices
slices of time. Each candle represent
time slice which is 10 seconds
white. Actually these are 10 seconds
only.
If I at the moment of closing the
session write down
all the waiting orders
at the slice
at each price level. I get a column of
numbers.
If this candle, I mean, I'm talking
about this candle. If this candle closed
and the numbers were like this in the
smart dome, I [music] got a column of
60,
30,
58,
40 and so on and so on. These are the
numbers of the orders in the market
which
are waiting to get filled. We have a
current price. This is the current
price.
This is the current price.
And below the current price, there are
also some orders waiting. 29, 34, 40,
29,
34,
40, and so on and so on. And we get a
column of numbers starting at this price
level because of my zoom of the chart
and ending at this price. And the column
consists of the asks above the price.
ask is above the price and bits below
the price. I I simply copy these numbers
from the smart dome to this column to
this slice of the time. And now how I
want to read that obviously I can read
the numbers. Then it looks like a
spreadsheet with a lot of numbers. I
need to search when I'm interested where
are the most waiting orders or the least
waiting orders.
The most waiting orders are actually
very interesting and very important.
This means that [music] there is a group
of traders, there are market
participants who are convinced that it
is a good idea to sell 60 contracts at
the price of 6859.
60 contracts. There can be 60 market
participants, one contract each or there
can be one market participant who
decided to sell 60 contracts here. And
you see that this level is interesting
because [music] when we read all the
numbers there's 58 which is quite close
to that obviously [music] but when I'm
reading the the column on the right side
as well as on the left side there is 53
which is close to 60.
60 was the highest number. There isn't
any number higher than that no matter if
below the price or above the price.
Important thing is that this number is
the [music] highest number. Now how can
I represent it? Obviously I can print
here in this slice 60. Yeah. And at this
level 58
and at this level 53. You know I'm just
basically copying these numbers. uh I
emphasize that we are at the 10-second
chart. Imagine the number
the amount of the numbers in the column
in the slice of the time and we can use
5 seconds, we can use 1 second. You will
not be able to read these numbers
obviously. So how how can we represent
these numbers so that you know
immediately what's happening at the
chart? Somebody [music] came up with the
idea that not each number but the range
of the numbers will be represented
through a gradient. The brighter the
color, the higher the number. [music] Or
you can use basically a gradient between
two colors. Let's say uh let's say that
if we have I will change it like this.
There will be zero obviously then there
will be let's say 30 and then there will
be 60
will be represented
by
yellow color everything what's 60 will
be yellow everything what's 30 will be
pink
and everything what's zero will be
transparent
and [music] in this case we Start
representing the values not through
numbers but through the color scala
gradient of a different colors. 60 will
be yellow. That's obvious. 60 is the
yellow color. Now 58 is almost the same
yellow. I will use the same yellow as
well as 53. It's almost the same color.
Now everything around 30 will be pink
color. We have do you see it here? We
have 30 below 60. So there will be pink
square or rectangle between those two
yellow rectangles because it's exactly
30 between 60 and 58.
But there are another levels with uh
something like 30. There is 35. So there
will be an orange. There will be the
pink rectangle as well. There is 36
which is also almost pink. I will use
the pink color. Then there is 32 26. So
32.
I'm not able to use another color. So
imagine this is a slightly more
transparent pink color and [music] so on
and so on. And all of the sudden instead
of reading all the numbers I just see
the colors
and the colors represent the values.
When I see the yellow color,
I immediately know that there's a high
number and I can actually
wait for the reaction to that level.
This is very very interesting. This is
basically what heat map displays.
Here's the core idea. Heat map doesn't
just show you where orders are. It shows
you how they are changing. Think about
it. People place orders, then they
cancel them. They move them around and
more. Pull out. The [music] market is
constantly shifting. Heat map captures
this movement. The color tells you the
story. Bright colors mean high interest
at that level. Faded colors mean low
interest and every few seconds it
updates. You see interest building up or
you see it disappearing.
This is what makes it different from a
regular chart. You are not just looking
at price. You are watching the intention
of market participants change in real
time. Now let me show you what this
looks like on a real chart.
When I remove all the paintings
and I simply add the heat map to the
chart. It's already added to the chart.
We have to wait a little a few moments
and you see the algorithm started
calculating and we get this. We get this
heat map. This is what heat map looks
like. This is how it is
displayed.
And actually
we see some very very interesting
things. We started seeing very
interesting things.
I'm talking for example about this
rectangle. Now it is a rectangle or
perhaps a line
in the width of one tick. You see that
line? This line started somewhere on the
left in the past because it represents
the slices. Do you remember each slice
is 10 seconds white.
And when we read the heat map in this
case that means that there were the
highest number of the waiting order in
the market during that time slice at
this price level as well as at this
price level. I bet those numbers were
very close to each other unlike for
example this rectangle.
We see the slices here. This is the
slice. This is the slice. There's the
slice. There are two slices.
There's the slice. There. There are two
slices next to each other. [music] Then
there's this slice. And so on and so on.
And the color of the slice of the small
rectangle tells us the development as
well as here. For example, you see that
there were barely any waiting orders at
this slice at this moment in time. Then
somebody added to to this level because
he expected probably pullback to the
level and expected the continuation of
the uptrend.
That was the reason why somebody pulled
to the position, added to the position.
Then somebody decided to add more
Then the number remained and somebody
decided to add even more and even more.
This is the orange the most orange color
in this entire rectangle or basically
not just rectangle at this price level
because it goes from the left side to
the right side. This is the [music]
development in price. So this means that
actually at this moment at this moment
there was the highest number of the
waiting buy orders because the price was
above that level obviously. So these
were waiting by orders and somebody
expected the continuation.
Do you see how the price went back to
those levels? And do you see this week
visiting those waiting orders
somebody actually
purchased at this level I don't know how
many we would see that we would have
seen that at the footprint the amount of
their ordered contracts and the price
[music] indeed developed a little higher
then it moved downwards but it [music]
doesn't matter it doesn't matter this
was the buy opportunity,
a very fast actually hyper fast buying
opportunity
and then the market developed one, two,
three ticks higher. So you could have
purchased here and [music] profit from
this tiny movement three ticks higher.
Now again I will be talking about this
rectangle. I will interpret, I will
decode, I will translate the information
given at this price level through this
rectangle. I will explain you what does
it mean. There was the price development
obviously.
There was something something happened
here you know and then the price started
developing downwards. You see low lower
low
high lower high lower high. So some
market participants thought wait this is
an interesting situation. The price
moved aggressively to this area and was
not able to go through. There must be
the reason. Everything moves because of
some reason. So this probably a barrier,
a resistance
which does not allow the price going
higher. In this situation, I want to
sell here because I think that the
market will not be able to pass this
level. I want to scalp. I want to open a
very fast short position. So I will
prepare for that and I will actually
place some limit
sell orders here. Then the other market
participants or maybe the same market
participant, it doesn't matter [music]
decided to add to the position. Do you
see this slice? This slice is slightly
slightly more yellow than the first one.
So either this market participant, the
initial one decided to increase his
position or somebody basically saw the
change because at the beginning there
were this blueish color and all of the
sudden there were this yellowish color
which represents the interest to sell.
Price was here. You see the candles
price was here. So somebody was going to
sell here. This was waiting limit sell
order. And at this slice the next 10
seconds somebody saw the change from the
bluish background to the yellowish
background. And he thought to themsel,
"Oh wait, wait, wait. Somebody is
probably going to sell here. So I will
join him. I will also want to sell here
and that's why the price became more
yellow. If you compare the backgrounds,
the difference is very subtle but the
difference is there and you can
basically see it uh more clearly when
you compare this yellow to this yellow.
You see more and more people started
realizing that somebody is going to sell
at this level. I want to sell as well. I
want to sell as well. Oh, I'm not sure.
The price is already quite down. I'm not
going to sell here. I'm pulling out the
the orders. That's why the color became
less yellow [music]
and started to having those blue tones
because do you remember the scale the
gradient the blueish the yellowish
orangeish the color is the more waiting
orders are in the market. But somebody
changed the mind and started adding to
position. And look here, this is the
brightest color at this level since the
beginning of changing the number of the
waiting limit sell orders at this slice.
But we have basically even more
orangeish color at this level. Somebody
was going to buy here and somebody was
going to buy here since the beginning.
There was the orange color. It became
orangeish. It became yellowish. It
became yellow and then somebody started
to adding to position and it became
orange again. So you see the development
that is the entire point of heat map.
[music] You don't see just the numbers
of the waiting limit orders. You also
see the development in time. And this is
the current chart. This is the current
situation. And you see that the interest
starts here that somebody decided to
join it. Then somebody decided to
decrease the number and then somebody
decided to add and you started seeing
this nice yellowish orangeish colors and
then the interest faded. You see those
less yellow [music] colors and basically
more and more blueish colors which which
which represents the lack of the
interest because the people changed
their mind. I don't know why maybe they
realized that this high was followed by
a lower high. So they didn't expect the
price to return to those areas. So these
waiting orders are basically obsolete,
pointless
because there was a price development.
That's why the heat map changes all the
time and that's why we can use the heat
map for supporting
our trading ideas. I don't know what was
at the 685125
level. I don't know maybe there was the
level
from the past some swing low some high
volume note or some low volume note
obviously some gap some order block
whatever but somebody waited here
patiently patiently at this order at
this limit at this price level waited
all the time till the price actually
comes to this level he waited that he
almost got filled. You see that the
price was here and he waited here with
his orders but the price reversed and
created this high. However, lower high
it's lower high which means that he
still waited. He still waited and the
price eventually went to the area hit
the waiting orders through the week.
this guy or these guys, these market
participants got filled, they purchased,
they bought S&P 500 contracts at this
price level through this VIC and they
joined this wonderful uptrend [music]
and they could have sold here. These
orders could be
uh actually waiting sell orders of these
contracts. Somebody could have purchased
here with the intention of selling here
or here because you see the bright
yellowish colors. Somebody could have
sold here and as soon as the price came
to these areas, he sold. All right,
let's wrap this up. Today you learned
what heat map actually is. It's a tool
that visualizes waiting orders in the
market. You see where they concentrate.
You see how interest changes over time
through color, through slices. The
brighter the color, the stronger the
level. The pattern of colors shows you
market intentions.
Now, here's the thing. Understanding how
it works is step one. But what matters
is using it in real trading. In the next
video, I will show you specific
strategies, how to use heat map to find
entry points, how to read order flow at
key levels, how to combine it with price
action, real examples, real setups, real
decisions.
If you want to see that, hit subscribe,
turn on the notifications so you don't
miss it. Thank you for watching. See you
in the next video.